President Trump is leaning on
congressional Republicans to finish tax
reform quickly he asked GOP House
members on a conference call to go along
with the Senate's budget blueprint that
would make it easier to pass the tax cut
the president will go to Capitol Hill
tomorrow to meet with Republican
senators there for the first time major
Garrett is at the White House with the
effort to win a legislative victory
major good morning good morning the
president's message to those House
Republicans can be summarized as follows
hurry up House GOP leaders still cling
to hopes they can pass a tax cut by
Thanksgiving two key benchmarks lie
ahead finalizing the budget this week
and releasing the tax cut legislation in
all those nitty-gritty details next week
there's a great spirit forward people
want to see it president Trump who for
days has hailed stock market records and
low unemployment said the economy still
needs trillions and tax cuts to spur
growth I call it tax cut so it is tax
reform also but I call it tax cuts it'll
be the biggest cuts ever in the history
of this country
Ohio Democratic senator sherrod Brown
said a trump administration staffed with
many former Goldman Sachs executives was
angling to benefit the wealthy instead
of the middle class the people closest
to the president whispering in his ear
all want to do tax cuts for wouldn't
want to do trickle-down economics the
president also purportedly wants a
short-term obamacare fix Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell said he's open to
bringing a bipartisan bill to the floor
that would restore seven billion dollars
in annual subsidies the president
eliminated almost two weeks ago we need
a bill the president will actually sign
and I'm not certain yet what the
president's looking for here when
Republican Lamar Alexander and Democrat
patty Murray announced their health care
deal the president at first supported it
that's a very good solution then he
dumped it with very little evidence mr.
Trump called the bill a giveaway to
insurance companies I won't do anything
to enrich the insurance companies
Alexander and Murray denied the charge
while Senate Democratic leader Chuck
Schumer said the president caved to
conservative pressure he called both
senators Murray and Alexander it's had
come to a solution then they come to a
solution the
right-wing attacks it and he backs off
that's not leadership the White House
has been vague on tax cut details
keeping them under wraps until the last
minute then hoping Republicans will
rapidly fall in line that was pretty
much the strategy behind three failed
attempts to repeal and replace Obamacare
the White House bet this time Norah the
fourth time is the charm all right let's
see you major thank you